انباء عن ابطاء فرنسا حزمه اوروبيه لشراء
اسلحه لاوكرانيا من خلال المطالبه بتصنيع
الذخائر داخل الاتحاد
الوكاله الذريه تجري تحقيقا حول اختفاء
طنين ونصف من اليورانيوم الطبيعي من موقع
ليبي
والمغرب يفكك خليه داعشيه متهمه بقتل شرطي
وحرقه وبالتخطيط لسرقه بنك لتمويل عمليتها
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
نقلت صحيفه تيليغراف عن مصادر اوروبيه ان
فرنسا تقف وراء تاخير حزمه المساعدات
الماليه التي خصصها الاتحاد الاوروبي
لمساعده اوكرانيا والتي تبلغ قيمتها 2
مليار يورو مقابل تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
لحمايه اراضيها واضافت الصحيفه ان باريس
تطالب بتصنيع الذخائر داخل الكتله
الاوروبيه وان تعود الاسلحه بالنفع على
الشركات التي تتخذ من الاتحاد مقرا لها
على ثلاثه مسؤولين اسرائيليين واوكرانيين
وفق ما نقله موقع اكسيوس قالوا ان اسرائيل
وافقت مؤخرا على تراخيص تصدير لبيع
المحتمل لانظمه تشويش مضاده للطائرات بدون
طيار يمكن ان تساعد اوكرانيا في مواجهه
الطائرات الايرانيه المسيره التي استخدمت
روسيا خلال الحرب فيما زعم المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون ان توفير انظمه الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا هو في مصلحه اسرائيل لان ايران
قادره على الحصول على معلومات حول كيفيه
اداء الطائرات بدون طيار ومن ثم اجراء
تحسينات وقال مسؤول اسرائيلي كبير لاكسيوس
ان احد اسباب موافقه اسرائيل على تراخيص
هو امكانيه رؤيه اداء انظمه الدفاع ضد
طائرات الايرانيه بدون طيار
وميدانيا قال الجنرال مايك ميلي رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه ان القوات
الروسيه حققت تقدما طفيفا في باخمه لكن
بتكلفه بشريه هائله مشيرا ايضا الى ان
هناك جهودا مستمره لبناء الجيش الاوكراني
ومساعدته للدفاع عن اوكرانيا
في الوقت الحالي هناك قتال عنيف في باخ
موتو محيطها الروس يحققون تقدما تكتيكيا
صغيرا لكن بتكلفه باهظه بينما لا يزال
الخط الامامي ثابتا نسبيا مع تبادل كبير
للقصف المدفعي دون تحقيق مكاسب هناك جهود
كبيره ومستمره لبناء الجيش الاوكراني من
حيث المعدات والذخيره والتدريب في مجموعه
من البلدان بهدف تمكين اوكرانيا من الدفاع
عن نفسها
مره جديده تقول قوه فاجنر الروسيه انها
اقتربت من تطويق مدينه باخموت الاوكرانيه
بالكامل المديده التي ارتبطت اسمها باطول
معركه في تاريخ اوروبا الحديث بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه القوات التي تقود
المعركه في باخمت نشرت صوره توضح
السيطرتها على خمس مدن جديده في محيط
المدينه وقالت انها تواصل المعركه حتى
السيطره عليها
بالمقابل يواصل الجيش الاوكراني التاكيد
على ثبات قواته في باغموت حيث تشير اخر
الصور القادمه من هناك الى انتشار الجنود
الاوكرانيين في مواقعهم بكامل معداتهم
واجهزتهم الحربيه والتكنولوجيا
وفقا لاحدث المعلومات القوات الروسيه
سيطرت على جميع الطرق المعبده التي تؤدي
الى باخموت مما يعرقل بشكل كبير امداد
الوحدات الاوكرانيه في المدينه
كانت فاجنر السيطره على الجانب الشرقي من
المدينه ليصبح النهر الذي يقسم المدينه
الى نصفين خط المواجهه المباشره بين
الطرفين
كذلك اعلنت قوات فاجنر في وقت سابق عن
افتتاح 58 مركزا للتجنيد في المدن الروسيه
فيما يبدو للدفع بمزيد من المقاتلين في
المعركه المصيريه بالنسبه اليها وموسكو
ومع استمرار القتال على جانبي نهر يستمر
الجانبان بالتراشق بالمعلومات والصور
معلومات ما زالت غير مؤكده حتى يثبت العكس
نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم من الجيش الامريكي حدث عن بعد برامج
حساسه من المسيره الامريكيه التي سقطت في
البحر الاسود لمنع روسيا من جمع معلومات
سريه واوضح المسؤولون ان القرارات تم
اتخاذه بعد المواجهه بين المسيره
الامريكيه والمقاتلتين الروسيتين في البحر
الاسود فيما افاد مسؤول في البحريه
الامريكيه بانه لا توجد لدى الولايات
المتحده اي سفن تابعه للبحريه في البحر
الاسود مما يجعل اي محاولات امريكيه
لانتشال حطام المسيره امرا صعبا للغايه
ويستغرق وقتا طويلا على حد قوله
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ان الطيران العسكريه الامريكي سيواصل
التحقيق في اطار القانون الدولي اكد اصلا
على روسيا تشغيل مقاتلتها بطريقه احترافيه
وامنه
مقاتلتان روسيتان القتال وقودها على مسيره
امريكيه كانت تقوم بمهمه عاديه في المجال
الجوي الدولي وحدث اصطدام مع مقاتله روسيه
هذا يعد حلقه متجدده من افعال الطيارين
الروس المتهوره في المجال الجوي الدولي
اجريت اتصالا هاتفيا مع نظير الروسي وكررت
انه من المهم ان تكون القوه العظمى مثالا
للشفافيه والتواصل الولايات المتحده
ستواصل التحليق في اطار القانون الدولي
ومن مهام روسيا ان تشغل مقاتلاتها بطريقه
احترافيه وامنه في المجال الجوي الدولي
في المقابل اكد مدير الاستخبارات الخارجيه
الروسيه
ناريش كين ان الولايات المتحده تقوم
بعمليات استطلاع الناشطه في منطقه البحر
الاسود باستخدام وسائل تكنولوجيه مختلفه
وقال ناريش كين ان الامريكيين يستخدمون
بنشاط كبير جميع الوسائل خصوصا الاستطلاع
البصري والاستطلاع اللاسلكي وقال مجلس
الامن الروسيه تحاول ايضا العثور على حطام
مسيره الامريكيه التي سقطت امس في البحر
الاسود
من جانبه اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بدات تحقيق في حادث المواجهه بين مسير
امريكيه ومقاتلات روسيه فوق البحر الاسود
وقال بلنكنن المواجهه امر متهور وغير امن
قبل ذلك قال متحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الحادثه من المحتمل ان يكون
عملا غير مقصود وقع بسبب عدم كفاءه
الطيارين الروس
في المقابل قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
الولايات المتحده كانت تتجاهل حقيقه ان
روسيا قد انشات مجالا جويا فوق البحر
الاسود
واضافره روسيا اسست حدود الرحلات الجويه
في المنطقه بعد بدء الحمله العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا وهي الحقيقه التي
تدركها الولايات المتحده جيدا
احتكاك روسي امريكي خطير مقاتله روسيه
مقابل مسيره امريكيه في تفاصيل الحادثه
التي وصفت بالخطيره
اصطدمت مقاتله روسيه من طراز سوخويت وانت
7 بطائره امريكيه مسيره من طراز ام كيو 9
ريبر وقالت واشنطن ان قواتها اضطرت الى
اسقاط مسيره في البحر الاسود اما موسكو
فتقول ان الحادثه وقعت بالقرب من جزيره
القرم لكن لماذا وجدت مسيره امريكيه
بطريقه استفزت روسيا فوق البحر الاسود
المسؤولون العسكريون الامريكيون يقولون ان
الطائره المسيره كانت تقوم بعمليات
روتينيه في المجال الجوي الدولي اما
البنتاجون فاستنكر الحادثه واتهم
المقاتلات الروسيه بالقاء الوقود امام
المسيرات الامريكيه الا انه رفض الافصاح
عما اذا كانت مسيره مسلحه ام لا
المهمه التي كانت تقوم بها بينما للروس
روايه اخرى فهم ينظرون للحادث باعتباره
استفزازا موسكو نفتعمدها اسقاط المسيره
الامريكيه وقالت ان ام كيو 9 ريبر تحطمت
بعد ارتطامها بسطح البحر الاسود لاسباب
تعود لفقدانها الارتفاع بعد قيامها
بمناوره حاده واثناء تحليقها اطفات اجهزه
تعريفها في انتهاك لمنطقه الحظر الجوي ما
دفع مقاتلتين روسيتين الاعتراضها الا
انهما لم تسقطاها ولم تقتربا منها بشكل
خطير مستبعدين رغبه موسكو بالمواجهه مع
واشنطن حتى الان للولايات المتحده ولا
روسيا تمكنتا من استعاده حطام المسيره
الامريكيه الا ان هذا التصعيد الاخير حذر
منه مسؤول البلدين خاصه وانه اول مواجهه
مباشره بين الطرفين منذ بدء الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا روان حمزه العربيه
من احدث المسيرات الامريكيه تمتلك مواصفات
تكنولوجيه عاليه
يعتمد عليها الجيش الامريكي في العمليات
العسكريه
سرعتها تصل الى 370 كيلو مترا في الساعه
قادره على التحليق لمده تصل الى اكثر من
30 ساعه تصنف بالطائره متعدده المهام
القدره على الرصد والمراقبه ومهاجمه اهداف
على الارض يمكن تسليحها بصواريخ هيل فاير
وكذلك بقنابل موجهه بالليزر نفذت ام كيو 9
مهمه في العراق وافغانستان وسوريا ودول
اخرى وفق تقارير استخدمت في اغتيال قاسم
سليماني وفي اغتيال زعيم تنظيم القاعده
ايمن الظواهري صحيفه واشنطن بوست تشغيل
الدرون ام كيو 9 يتم عن بعد بواسطه فريقين
في نحو 20 قاعده منتشره في 17 ولايه
امريكيه
اعلنت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اختفاء عشر اسطوانات تحوي نحو طنين ونصف
من اليورانيوم الطبيعي من موقع معلن في
ليبيا به تركيزات لليورانيوم الخام واوضحت
الوكاله الذريه في بيان ان ذلك الموقع لا
يخضع حاليا لسيطره الهيئه النوويه الليبيه
والفحص كان مقررا العام الماضي لكنه تاجل
لاسباب امنيه الوكاله اكدت انها ستجري
مزيدا من التحقيقات الاصطلاحي ملابسات
ازاله هذه المواد وموقعها الحالي وحضرت
الوكاله من ان عدم معرفه مكان هذه المواد
ربما يشكل خطرا اشعاعيا ويثير كذلك مخاوف
تتعلق بالامان النووي
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي والشباك والشرطه عن
انفجار عبوه الناسفه في منطقه شمال
اسرائيل مطلع هذا الاسبوع اسفلت عن اصابه
اسرائيلي وقال البيان المشترك للجهات
الامنيه الثلاث انه تم تحديد منفذ الهجوم
في مستوطنه عاره مشيرا الى انه كان في
سياره وتم قتله والعثور على اسلحه وحزام
ناسف بحوزته وبحسب تحقيقات الاسرائيليه
فقد تسلل المنفذ من الاراضي اللبنانيه
وانه لا يزال
تحقيق او لا يزال هناك تحقيق موسع يجري
حول العمليه وعن مدى تورط حزب الله فيها
يوم الاثنين انفصلت عبوه نسف بالقور
المفترق مجيده مما ادى الى اصابه مواطن
اسرائيلي بشروخ خطيره على اثر ذلك قامت
قوتنا بعمليه تمشيط واغلاق طرق في منطقه
الشمال واوقفت السياره مشبوهه حيث شكل
الارهابيا المصالحه الذي كان بداخلها خطرا
على قوه الشباب والشرطه التي قامت بتحيده
وقتله لقد اثرت القوات بحوض هذا المقرب
الاسلحه وحزام ناسخ جاهل للاستخدام واغراض
اخرى تشير التقديرات الى ان التحديدا
الارهابيه المسلح حاله دون وقوف هجوم
ارهابي اخر يظهر تحقيق الاول لانني
ارهابيت سلم على ما يبدو من داخل الاراضي
اللبنانيه الى اسرائيل في وقت سابق من هذا
الاسبوع ويجرى تحقيق موسع حول العمليه
التخريبيه وفي اطارها ياتي مفحص مدى تورط
مناظره حزبال الارهابيه في هذه العمليه
الى ذلك اكدت مصادر العربيه انه تم التحقق
او التحقيق في تسلل منفذين اثنين للهجوم
عبر نفق تحت الارض يتبع لحزب الله اضافت
المصادر ان المنفذين فلسطينيين قتل الجيش
الاسرائيلي احدهما ونجح الاخر في العوده
الى لبنان واضافت مصادر العربيه ان
اسرائيل لم تكشف او تكتشف النفق لفتره
طويله وانه ربما تم استخدامه لعمليه تهريب
او دخول منفذيه هجمات ايضا
قبل ذلك قال رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي
ان بلاده تراقب انشطه حزب الله وتفهم ان
عليها الاستعداد واضافها ان اسرائيل يجب
ان تكون مستعده في السنوات القادمه لاحدث
متعدد الجبهات تشارك فيه ايران
هذه النشره مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
وزراء الخارجيه ووزراء خارجيه منظمه
التعاون الاسلاميه يبحثون على مدى يومين
في نواكشوط قضايا الارهاب والاسلام وفوبيا
والاقليات المسلمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اوقفت السلطات المغربيه
ثلاثه داعشيين يشتبه في قيامهم بقتل شرطيا
عثر على جثته متفحمه مطلع مارس الجاريه
قرب الدار البيضاء ووفقا لبيان مديريه
الامن الوطني المغربي فان المتهمين بقتل
الشرطي والاستيلاء على سلاحه
ومتعلقاته كانوا يخططون للسطو على احدى
المؤسسات البنكيه لتمويل مخططهم الارهابي
داخل البلاد
تنطلق في العاصمه الموريتانيه الدوره
التاسع والاربعون لمجلس وزراء الخارجيه
بمنظمه تعاون الاسلامي ويبحث المؤتمر على
مدى يومين مستجدات القضيه الفلسطينيه
وتطورات الوضع في مالي وساحه والساحل
وقضايا الاقليات المسلمه عبر العالم كما
سيتم بحث جهود مواجهه التطرف العنيف
والاسلام فوبيا
رحب المبعوث الاممي الخاص الى اليمن هانز
كرومبر بالجهود المستمره لانهاء الصراع في
اليمن خاصه من جانب السعوديه وسلطنه عمان
مطالبا باغتنام الفرصه التي اوجدها الحراك
السلمي بالمنطقه
جهود دبلوماسيه مكثفه تبدل على مستويات
مختلفه لانهاء الصراع في اليمن نشهد زخما
دبلوماسيا اقليميا وتغييرا تدريجيا في
نطاق وعمق المناقشات ارحب بالجهود
المستمره للدول الاعضاء في المنطقه خاصه
السعوديه وسلطنه عمان واطالب الاحزاب
باغتنام الفرصه التي اوجدها الحراك
الاقليمي
احتفل عنصر رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق عمران خان اثراء تعليقي امر
اعتقاله بعد عده ايام من المواجهات مع
الشرطه في مدينه لاهرجان وبشرق البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق
عمران خان قال انه لا ينتابه اي قلق من
الذهاب الى السجن او المحاكم مشيرا الى ان
القلق الوحيد يكمن في ان هذه الخطوه قد
تاتي بهدفي تزوير الانتخابات من خلال
ابعاده عن المشهد السياسي ان الذهاب الى
السجن او المحاكم لا يقلقني لانه ليس لدي
ما يدعو الى القلق بشان اي من هذه التهم
قال قيل وحيد هو ان هذا الامر يحدث لانهم
يريدون تزوير الانتخابات انهم يريدون
تزوير الانتخابات بابعاد عن الطريق اولا
ثم يبتعد بعض كبار اعضاء حزب عن الطريق
قال الممثل الامريكي الخاص افغانستان توم
سواست لقناه
تولونيوز الافغانيه انها طالبان لم تقف لم
تفي بالتزاماتها بعدم استضافه المتطرفين
الذين يرغبون في الحاق الاذى بدول اخرى
وبعدم السماح بالتدريب او التجنيد او جمع
الاموال في اراضيها واكد مسؤولون امريكيون
ان هناك اكثر من عشرين جماعه مسلحه في
افغانستان وحدها ومما يثير القلق بشكل خاص
الوجود النشط في افغانستان لحركه طالبا
باكستان وهي جماعه متمرده اعلنت مسؤوليتها
عن هجمات ارهابيه عده في باكستان خلال
الاشهر القليله الماضيه وفقا لشبكه فويس
منذ ثلاثه عقود والقلق ما زال يسود
الولايات المتحده بشان وجود مقاتلي
القاعده وقادتها بافغانستان
انخرطت الولايات المتحده في افغانستان بعد
هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر للبحث عن قاده
القاعده في اطول حرب خارجيه في تاريخ
امريكا في عام 2022 قتل زعيم القاعده ايمن
الظواهري في كابول في غاره امريكيه بطائره
مسيره وهو امر رفضته طالبان بان الظواهري
قتل في كابول مسؤولون امريكيون يقولون ان
زعيم القاعده الجديد سيف العدل وهو ضابط
سابق في القوات الخاصه المصريه يتواجد في
ايران وسط نافيين من طهران
شارك مائه الالاف من العمال من بينهم
المدرسون والاطباء وعملوا قطار الانفاق في
اضراب عن العمل في بريطانيا للمطالبه
بزياده رواتب وتحسين ظروف العمل في واحد
من اكبر موجه الاحتجاجات التي بدات العام
الماضي واعتزامنت الاضرابات التي شلت
قطاعات واسعه مع تقديم وزير الخزانه
لميزانيه العام القادم
[موسيقى]
موعد الاحتجاجات هذه ليست صدفه 400 الف
عامل من موظفي القطاع العام من بينهم عمال
مترو الانفاقنا في لندن يضربون عن العمل
تزامنا مع اعلان الميزانيه العامه في مجلس
العموم تحاول النقابات من خلال هذه
الاحتجاجات والاضات الضغط على الحكومه من
اجل رفع اجورهم وتخليصهم من اعباء البلاد
الاقتصاديه التي يقولون انها اصبحت سيئه
للغايه
[تصفيق]
انا اشارك في الاضراب حقيقه لكل ما يحدث
في هذا البلد ليس فقط من اجل المعلمين
ولكن لكافه العاملين في البلاد
انا هنا اليوم لادعم والدتي لانها مدرسه
دائما ما تتاخر ولا تصل المنزل الا بعد
حلول الليل
وزير الماليه في مجلس العموم اليوم رد على
الغاضبين من الميزانيه العامه بضريبه على
ارباح الشركات وباجراءات اجتماعيه قلم
تتخذها حكومه يمنيه محافظه
[تصفيق]
بسبب العوامل الدوليه المتغيره والتدابير
التي اتخذتها لن تدخل بريطانيا في ركود
هذا العام
لكن لا يبدو ان المحتاجين هنا مقتنعون
بالموازنه الجديده حيث يصلون على ان موظفي
القطاع العام هم جديرون برفع اجورهم
اضرابات واحتجاجات اعطت فرصه للاحزاب
السياسيه المعارضه وعلى راسها حزب العمال
لنسم الوضع الاقتصادي المتردي لسياسات
تقول انها فاشله من قبل حزب المحافظين
الحاكم منذ اكثر ما يزيد على عقد من الزمن
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
بدا المدعون
الفيدراليون في نيويورك بفحص ما اذا كانت
شركه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التابعه
لدونو ترامب تنتهك قوانين غسيل الاموال
وبحسب الجاردن يجري تحقيق في قبول شركه
ترامب للاعلام لثمانيه ملايين دولار من
الاموال الروسيه المشبوهه ويبحث المدعون
الفيدراليون في تحويل الاموال لشركه ترامب
من بنوك في منطقه الكريب من كيانات غامضه
يبدو انها تخضع لسيطره احد الاثرياء الروس
المقربين من بوتين
محكمه هولنديه في دعوه جماعيه الى ان
الشركه الاوروبيه تابعه لشركه متى استخدمت
بشكل غير صحيح بينت شخصيه لمواطنين
هولنديين في الفتره ما بين عامي 2010
و2020 لاغراض الاعلانات لكن القضيه
الهولنديه لم تصل بعد الى مرحله المطالبه
باي تعويضات
تسببت الفيضانات التي ضربت جنوب تركيا
بمقتل عده اشخاص اضافه لفقدان اخرين ما
زالت السلطات تبحث عنهم حيث شهدت المنطقه
التي ضربها الزلزال هطولات مطريه كبيره
خلال 24 او الاربعه والعشرين ساعه الماضيه
بعد الزلزال فيضانات تضرب مناطق بجنوب
تركيا
الفيضانات ضربت ولايه
المعلومات تؤكد وقوع قتلى سوريين واتراك
بينهم اطفال
كميات الامطار التي هطلت على الولايتين
تراوحت بين 111 الى 136 ملم في المتر مربع
بعض الصور اظهرت السيوله تجري ف اناسا
وسيارات في الولايتين
ابرزها انقاذ طفله وامراه في اللحظات
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
خدام هذه النشره الى العناوين
انباء عن ابطاء فرنسا حزمه اوروبيه لشراء
اسلحه لاوكرانيا من خلال المطالبه بتصنيع
الذخائر داخل الاتحاد
الوكاله الذريات تجري تحقيقا حول اختفاء
طنين ونصف من اليورانيوم الطبيعي من موقع
ليبي
والمغربي يفكك خليه داعشيه متهمه بقتل
شرطي وحرقه وبالتخطيط لسرقه بنكا لتمويل
عملياتها
دائما مشاهدينا العربيه
شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]